[Music]
i have with me
david pakman he is a progressive host
and executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david patman
he is a beta male 1
david pacman he is a baby
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah
male 1 they think and act like a woman
they are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a baby male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse well we got it
that's a lot that's a lot we would
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male dog
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pacman
he is a baby
david pacman he is
all i want to do is this i just want to
find
11 780
votes which is one more that we have
because we wanted to say you know what
they did and you're not reporting it
that's it
you know that's a number of 11 779
that's the number
of 11 779 that's the number
of 11 711
[Music]
that's something i think everyone at
least that's the number that everyone
agrees on
but that's the difference in the votes
we've had uh hundreds of thousands of
ballots that we're uh we're we're able
to
actually we'll get you a pretty accurate
number you don't need much of a number
because the number that
in theory i lost by the number of eleven
thousand seven hundred and seventy nine
that's the number of eleven thousand
seven hundred and seventy nine that's
the number of eleven thousand
seven hundred and eleven hundred and
eleventy nine eleven nine
eleven seventy
[Music]
have they have they moved the inner
parts of the machines
and replaced them with other parts no
you sure ryan i'm sure
i'm sure mr president trump won the
military by a lot you know
a tremendous amount but these ballots
were 100 percent forbidden
and you know about that a very
substantial number came in
all from us does anybody know about it
all right welcome everybody we're
standing by for joe biden the united
states reaching really a tragic
milestone today
or yesterday or it depends on exactly
which source you look at
when it was reached and what the number
is but uh without a doubt at this point
officially over 500 000 coronavirus
deaths
in the united states um according to the
world domiter's website
512 000 if you assume
that or not you don't have to assume if
you understand that it's believed
there are far more coronavirus deaths
than the official number
we may already be at six hundred
thousand six hundred and fifty thousand
000
it is higher than this number for sure
because we know we know there were
people that did die
um who likely had the virus
they were never tested and uh in any
case at
some point you have to say well now it
is officially 500 000 and joe biden will
be commemorating this
a little bit later today uh we do have
even though it's a
horrible horrible day uh we do have
some interesting different things to
look at we're going to talk about cpac
we will adjudicate some unban requests
now by popular demand
i did get a gavel and it does squeak
which i will use when i
um when this court makes adjudications
on unbanned requests we will be able to
uh gavel in gavel in and gavel out we
will be uh
um we will be uh convening i guess as a
court of unban requests now
let's just test whether this is picked
up by my mic
i can't really slam it down on my desk
but let me see if i
i have a thing over here let's see if we
can hear this
that's audible right that little squeak
you guys can hear that
can people hear that
i mean i could also do this watch if
you're watching headphones
watch your ears i i could hit it against
the mic i just don't know if that'll be
any good okay
just stand by because i'm about to do it
what do people think about that
it is quite literally a ban hammer
better oh interesting okay yeah i could
do it on my head
that's that's not a bad idea anyway
we'll try not to completely humiliate me
by the end of the stream but we will get
to that a little bit later
it sounds like a cricket oh the head was
the best okay
all right we'll do that fine so we've
got that and we're going to look at some
different things now
before we even go anywhere else let me
just do some quick math because
we we actually do have a dramatically
improving coronavirus situation in the
united states let's pull up the
calculator
we peaked in terms of average cases
uh on january 11th exactly as i
predicted
okay since then average daily cases are
all the way down to 69 to 35
that's a decline of 73 percent
that's a massive decline in coronavirus
cases that's really really good
okay if we want to look at deaths
deaths are still tragically high
but they peaked on what was the date
uh it was three four four nine
january 26 on average of three four four
nine
we now have gotten all the way down to
1980.
case uh deaths rather are down
almost 43 percent still too many
still a tragedy still a disaster
but these are dramatically improving
numbers from the standpoint of
vaccines we now we had these
terrible uh slowdowns because of the
storms
but we are still averaging 1.6 million a
day over the last week
dr anthony fauci says that we're going
to be able to make up
the missed vaccines uh over the next
seven to ten days or so
and um that's all very very good news
okay so we did cases and deaths
and we did vaccines oh we'll get to the
voting a little bit later
okay so that's that and we're going to
hear from joe biden today
about um uh these 500 000
deaths um expectation is that joe biden
will announce
five days of all federal flags at half
mast in honor one day for each hundred
thousand dead i mean just inconceivable
inconceivable
numbers but hopefully things are going
to start improving
all right the super chats are coming in
chaka seki says trump's tax is soon to
be as visible
as the panty creepy rudy ogled at the on
the golf course
yikes jack clark says hey dp the
majority report had john fetterman on
their show last week i wanted to know if
you plan on having
20 22 candidates on the program i would
love to
in fact let's send an email right now to
producer pat
let's try to get john fetterman on the
show
he reportedly did
majority report boom all right
we have made that request to producer
pat and we'll see if he can get it
booked
um pepe xanadu says would you show us
your hairstyles
in chronological order from childhood to
present
that i don't know about i would be
willing to show one old hairstyle
um now let me think of how i can pull
this up
um how can i even do this
let me think photos
i should actually be able to let's see
if i can find
i think people would actually be highly
highly disturbed by my old
hairstyle let me
can i do this share external
email to myself
this this may actually end the show
it's extraordinarily risky let me see if
i can find this picture
oh all right let's download
save i am warning people
that this is i mean listen i don't uh
i was not in charge of anything at this
time at this age
photos here we go check this out this
was my old hairstyle
i would love to go back this is just
taking a moment to load let me actually
load it off screen just to make sure
nothing weird happens
uh here we go check this out that is my
old hairstyle
isn't that something i mean that is i
i've read you could be arrested for that
in certain states
not states i've ever lived in but
certainly some states
so anyway this is like my original
hairstyle
and um yeah
that's it all right so we've gotten that
out of the way
by popular popular demand okay other
super chats coming in
pedro says that's a chip chipot
chilean like the chapel lean i don't
know what this is out
did you mean to i don't know i don't
know what that's about
scott says david i finally got my
alfajor it's not bad not as
life-changing as i hope they're like a
fancy version of a wagon wheel
i've never had a wagon wheel i don't
know what that is and miscellaneous user
says finally able to get the vaccine in
oklahoma
very glad to hear that very very glad to
hear that
that's really good news okay let's go
into
adjudicating our unban requests before i
do that
i do want to say thank you to the six
people that just signed up
via twitch and twitch prime putting us
at okay it's zero plus six
so we started at zero we added six
that's six
for the day also wanna say thank you to
alex garcia for signing up at
joinpakman.com
and derek vidal for signing up at
joinpackman.com
putting us at eight very much appreciate
that no calculator needed for that one
and
um oh yeah so
i want to mention yeah people are
mentioning this i
uh i read something about
90 of twitch viewers never use
their twitch prime sub they just don't
use it they leave the money in jeff
bezos pocket
if that's the case that's very
disturbing uh you guys tell me if that's
true
but i i read something that uh of people
who have a twitch prime sub to use
90 just don't use it uh because they
either don't have their twitch linked to
amazon or they don't understand it or
i don't know that's that's really that's
disturbing okay
uh voicemails i have one voicemail from
a new caller new outrageous caller
which i'm going to play for you guys and
then i have three possible voicemails
from troy york
now ordinarily we would just vote on
whether to play the troy york voicemails
but last week a few people took
issue with using that voting system so
we're going to do a preliminary vote
today okay
the first this is like the senate where
they vote on the rules for voting
the first one which i'm going to paste
right now
in twitch and in youtube is should we
vote
on weather to play troy york's super
chats
okay i'm pasting the link to this first
vote in twitch and youtube
and i'm not going to be voting but let's
go to the results
this vote will determine whether
we use voting as the mechanism to decide
what to do about troy york voicemails
this is a simple majority this is a
simple majority it is not 60
okay so feel free to get those votes in
100 people voting
and overwhelmingly by a greater than two
to one margin in the early
in the early returns people do want
voting as the mechanism
to determine whether we will be using
the voting system to play a troy or
voicemails this is very interesting
up to almost a three to one margin with
259 votes
we are voting on whether to vote
on troy york voicemails up to 300 votes
still roughly a three to one margin
um get those votes in
this is not a vote on whether to play
them this is merely a vote as to whether
to vote on
playing them okay one more time i will
paste the link in twitch chat
as well as in youtube chat it's this is
this is not the vote
this is a vote on voting we we are
turning the show into the us senate
um really i should have had a vote on
whether to vote
about whether voting is the right
mechanism but then it's infinitely
regressive
so it's just this 420 430 votes
roughly by a three to one margin people
like voting
450 votes
we do have spam protection and i am
ready to call this
484 votes we'll give it just a few more
seconds
at 500 i'll cut it there it is okay
by a roughly three to one margin people
want
to use voting now let's go to the second
poll
we are now voting on playing the
voicemails
okay i am pasting a new link in twitch
chat
and i am pasting a new link in youtube
chat
we are now voting do you want me to play
the new troy york voicemails that
infected
our voicemail number over the weekend
this vote is now live it this is a
straight up and down vote
yes no voting is on the way based on
oh tighter much tighter based on the
first 250 votes it's only 60 40.
not even
6238 and the votes accumulating
much more quickly here already over 433
votes
uh roughly two to one not the three to
one we were seeing before
wow over 500 votes this could be a
record in terms of votes
i will paste the link to this poll one
more time as we stand by for joe biden
we
we have passed an initial what we would
call a procedural vote where we
established that voting would be used to
determine whether to play troy york
voicemails
this is now the actual vote and it is a
simple majority
maybe later in the week we we could
decide whether a supermajority would be
necessary
uh or even a two-thirds vote okay
630 votes it is now a margin it is
starting to get difficult to overcome
it's almost a 200 vote margin for yes
do we have to vote for each of troy's
personas that's a good question no
this is just it's a flat out vote
that's it next we will vote on
whether we should count this vote yeah
exactly all right i'm calling it 732
votes 753 votes
that is it folks we are going to play uh
some of these troy york voicemails
this is a really angry caller let's go
in chronological order i guess here is
the first one he left two days ago yes
referring to
responding to the voicemail video on
your youtube site of a female who called
and she
asked what it takes to
[Music]
impeach trump and what kind of country
actually the question should be
that was her opinion but the vast
majority of people
are asking what kind of country attempts
to impeach a man who's no longer
president
and what well actually trump was
impeached while president i
i think some people maybe don't
understand
time and uh but trump when trump was
impeached he was president
they say about the democrat party and
the fascists that run that party
the anti-american sickness that all
right so anyway that's that
and then he left another one on the same
day
they're very boring this is woody
underwood i just want to let you know
um i decided to blog about you an
article about
your opinion jank uger's opinion
uh sam cedar's opinion your evil sick
disgusting repulsive opinion of
the death of rush limbaugh i said i
don't wish illness or death upon every
anyone but he's a terrible person that's
weird
okay and then lastly he left one more
early this morning
yes david pagman i saw your caller about
the masks and he's wondering why are
people still not wearing masks
and he says it's been one year and you
admit the cases are down
and i wonder how many years do you full
think you're going to
turn the public into wearing masks my
expectation is we'll actually see some
states
probably start to get away from mask
mandates by the
my prediction actually is by the end of
may i'm not saying that's the right or
wrong
thing but i think you're going to start
to see some states ease off uh within
the next couple of months
okay so that's that that we're done with
troy york now let me introduce here is a
new caller
new caller exclusive to the david pakman
show
um let me know if this is someone you
want to hear from again or never again
take a listen
here we go hey bro since you hate
america so much won't you go back and
live in
argentina where you're from
where you were born right you would fit
in way better than argent
peta you cut on ron
johnson ron johnson
has accomplished more in his life than
you ever will
well i mean it's i don't know how anyone
can make a claim about the future
he's like twice my age so if he if we'd
accomplished the same it would be weird
dream of son i mean you can keep
dogging down on him and ted cruz who is
literally 100 iq points smarter than you
are
that i doubt now that i actually doubt
but um
it's [ __ ] embarrassing you're an
embarrassment bro just because you're
jealous of these guys only you gotta
rag down on them every day because you
disagree with their politics
right i mean
you the young turks
you guys inner internet
generation are
a lot to blame for the division in this
country
all right that you spread the [ __ ]
that comes out of your mouth every day
old trump don't know which car to get
into that's because there are six or
seven of them there
man so really is it typical that when
trump gets off air force one his car is
the one
seven cars away is that have you ever
seen that with any president ever
told what about five you know talk about
biden's town hall
we did how many how many times he
dropped the ball i did speak yeah
all right so anyway that's a new caller
i don't know if people are interested in
that
but it is it is what it is as the kids
say these days
thanks to jacob mckee for signing up at
joinpackman.com also amber johnson
amber thank you so much for your support
uh join these great folks at
joinpackman.com and also
a huge dump of twitch subs
27 people just grabbed twitch subs
which i absolutely love so it is
all happening today i have one
unbanned request to adjudicate okay we
are going to do it right now
i do have by popular demand a gavel
where i will be issuing my ruling on
unbanned requests
we are convening as a court of uh twitch
bans
a user sent a few messages
let's see why they were banned
uh okay let's see most recently what
they said
they said what's up my betas
david come here still relying on
flip-flop fouchy
wtf and then they were banned
their unbanned request is i don't think
i said anything untrue
fouchy obfuscated and withheld important
info on masks early on
isn't that something people should know
you know this caller is is wrong we now
know a lot about
why the comments were said early on
about masks
but i believe that this is not a
perma-ban
it's dishonest but it's not perma-ban
worthy
uh and i am ruling on an unban
there it is and we are going to unban
them and that user has been
unbanned that's not worthy of a perma it
was just a
it was just a uh temporary sort of like
a timeout
it functioned as a timeout and that's
all i have
as far as twitch unban
requests we are now going back to
regular order we are no longer
convened as a uh as an unban
adjudication court okay i missed a ton
of super chats
let me look at some of them here when
people are in my car in the afternoon
they know they're listening to david
pakman some substantive intellectual
discussion and no celebrating deaths
we don't celebrate deaths on this uh on
this show
is that a chapulin colorado hammer man i
just don't know what that is
let me see i don't know the reference
antagonistic representation from oh from
el chavo
i don't i just don't know i just don't
know what this is
i just don't know what it is imagine
hating david so much that you
intensively research him in his life
in order to then call him and rant using
this information who lives like that
sadly many people
all the link in the chat did on my
samsung tablet was give me an
error message okay i am ambivalent on
troy york
hate to use up live stream space with
bad behaviors though feels like a reward
to them yeah it's more of a sociological
thing but if people don't want the troy
york stuff anymore
by all means let's just vote it down
david respectfully troy voicemails are
boring
not voting on your troy york poll but i
respectfully think you demean yourself
by making him your co-star
people have to vote people absolutely
have to vote if that's the case
david can you do more videos about
anti-semitism oh you guys want to see
something
take a look at this take a look at this
cpac is this weekend okay
cpac yanks a speaker after anti-semitic
pro pizzagate post surface
okay a planned feature guest at this
week's
cpac with a history of making
anti-semitic conspiratorial comments
will no longer be speaking at the event
cpac announced monday
the speaker who goes by young pharaoh
once tweeted out that quote there is no
historical
or scientific evidence proving the
existence of jews or judaism
it's all a complete lie completely made
up for political gain
he also attacked fellow conservative
commentator
ben shapiro for his judaism according to
media matters which first reported the
post
his conspiracies aren't limited to the
jewish faith he's also
tweeted false claims about pizzagate and
that covet 19 vaccine changes your
genetic makeup
which it does not i like that
clarification now check this out this is
so funny
cpac tweeted we have just learned that
someone we invited to cpac has expressed
reprehensible views
that have no home with our conference or
our organization
the individual will not be participating
in our conference to which i tweeted
um doesn't this apply to every single
speaker at cpac
in fact i think i'm going to tweet hold
on here
cancel culture strikes again cpac
cancels young
pharaoh lots of
right wing cancellation fox news
just recently canceled
lou dobbs crazy
and then i actually found video of this
young pharaoh i've never seen i don't
know anything about this guy let's just
take a listen that level of
understanding
if we cursing each other out and acting
crazy during this during this exchange
so this is a video called
the hebrews were never enslaved by the
egyptians
i wanted to put that on the wax uh i'm
about to allow my guest now
to introduce himself so i'm switching
the camera to my guest now there he is
and uh bro you can introduce yourself uh
you know whatever if you got anything
going on
individually you can shout it out shout
your social okay anyway
that's who was going to speak right
before trump at cpac
uh due to his claims that uh jews are
thieving and don't actually exist or
whatever
um that he will no longer uh
he will no longer be speaking at cpac
trump still will
shockingly um but he is not going to be
he is not going to be speaking so that's
the young pharaoh material
and um okay so we've gotten that done i
have a whole agenda here for us as we
wait for joe biden
oh and looks like joe biden's about to
start
stand by for live video oh here's
something just really funny check this
out
one of our viewers called into the sam
cedar show the other day this was
brilliant check this out
from a 2 0 9 number calling from a 209
member
oh yes hello emma this is daniel from
california daniel from california how
you doing
good so i know you like to use
the sound board yeah so can i get can i
get it so
far for being a member uh sure
a shofar for daniel for being a member
i don't know if sam would approve of the
uh the lucy goosey use of the shofar but
i mean i think
you know you uh you deserve it for being
a member and everybody else who's
watching should become one
well i'm sorry i didn't finish my
sentence a member of the david packing
show
oh [ __ ] i'm hanging up on you
no i'm sorry again i i still didn't
finish my sentence oh
and a member of the majority report all
right wow
that was pretty nicely done i like that
whoever i don't know exactly who did
that i think i just don't remember
more like it but um that was very nicely
done
really really nicely done and i
appreciate that okay thanks to michael
pack not pacman just michael pack
for signing up at joinpakman.com
if you've been thinking about becoming a
member
there really is no better time to do it
i don't know why but it's just a good
time for it
also thanks to uh david chadman
for subscribing now for 17 months on
twitch as well as a harp and kinerick
three more there putting us at
41 some other super chats coming in
thoughts on trump offering kim jong-un a
ride on
air force one unrelated but watching pog
champs and hikaru still calls you david
pac-man that's funny
uh i didn't i didn't see that yeah i
mean i don't even know what to think
about trump offering kim jong-un a ride
on air force one it's just
it's just weird i don't even know what
to make of it
hey deepak or should i call you cpac
nice mo larry and curly would love the
gavel keep it up judge pacman
yeah people are mentioning that uh i
i did yeah speaking of hair i'll just
show this i posted this to my instagram
over the weekend
super windy really really windy
completely sideways wind i mean it's not
that interesting but this is just what
happens when there's wind and it's
really
it was weaponized completely and totally
weaponized you would know about that
if you were following me on instagram at
david.pakman
all right uh we are going to hear from
president joe biden
let's take a listen
each day i receive a small card
in my pocket that i carry with me my
schedule
and shows the number of americans who've
been infected
by or died from cover 19.
today we mark a truly grim
heartbreaking milestone
five hundred thousand seventy one
dead that's more americans
who've died in one year this pandemic
then in world war one world war
ii and the vietnam war combined
that's more lives lost to this virus
than any other nation on earth
but as we acknowledge the scale of this
mass death
in america we remember each person
and the life they lived they're people
we knew
they're people we feel like we knew
read the obituaries and remembrances
the son who called his mom every night
just to check in the father's
daughter who lit up his world
the best friend who was always there
the nurse the nurse and nurses
but the nurse who made her patients want
to live
i was in just in kalamazoo michigan at
the pfizer vaccine manufacturing
facility
there i met a man when i walked in whose
father-in-law was dying of the virus
he was sad i asked if i could call his
father-in-law
he said his father-in-law was too sick
to speak
but then he said but could i pray for
him
could i pray for him we all know someone
fellow americans who live lives of
struggle
purpose and of hope
who talked late in the night about their
dreams
who wore the uniform born to serve
who loved played and always offered a
hand
we often hear people described as
ordinary americans
there's no such thing there's nothing
ordinary about them
the people we lost were extraordinary
they spanned generations
born in america immigrated to america
but just like that so many of them took
their final breath
alone in america
as a nation we can't accept such a cruel
fate
while we've been fighting this pandemic
for so long
we have to resist becoming numb to the
sorrow
right we have to resist
viewing each life as a as a statistic
or a blur or on the news
we must do so to honor the dead
but equally important care for the
living those who left behind
for the loved ones left behind i know
all too well
i know what it's like to not be there
when it happens
i know what it's like when you are there
holding their hands just look in your
eye and they slip away
that black hole in your chest you feel
like you're being sucked into it
the survivor's remorse the anger
the questions of faith in your soul
for some of you it's been a year a month
a week a day
even an hour
and i know that when you stare at an
empty chair
around the kitchen table it brings it
all back no matter how
long ago it happened as if it just
happened that moment you look at an
empty chair
the birthdays the anniversaries the
holidays without them
and the everyday things the small things
the tiny things
that you missed the most that scent when
you open the closet
that park you go by they used to stroll
in
movie theater where you met
the morning coffee you shared together
the bend in his smile a perfect pitch to
her laugh
received a letter from a daughter whose
father died of covet 19 on easter sunday
last year
she and her children his grandchildren
and her lent this season a season of
reflection and renewal
with heavy hearts unable to properly
mourn she asked me in the letter
what was our loss among so many others
well that's what has been so cruel
so many of the rituals that help us cope
that help us honor those we loved
haven't been available to us
the final rights with family gathered
around
the proper homegoing showered with
stories and love
tribal leaders passing out the final
traditions of sacred cultures on sacred
lands
as a nation we cannot
and we must not let this go on
that's why the day before my
inauguration
at the kova 19 memorial at the
reflecting pool
on the national mall i said to heal to
heal
we must remember i know it's hard i
promise you i know it's hard i remember
but that's how you heal you have to
remember
and it's also important to do that as a
nation
for those who've lost loved ones
this is what i know they're never truly
gone
they'll always be part of your heart
i know this as well and it seems
unbelievable
but i promise you the day will come
and the memory of the loved one you lost
will bring a smile to your lips before
a tear to your eye it will come i
promise you
my prayer for you though is that they
will come
sooner rather than later and that's when
you know
you're going to be okay you're going to
be okay
and for me the way through
sorrow and grief is the fine purpose
i don't know how many you've lost
someone a while ago wondering
is he or she proud of me now this is
what they want me to do
i know that's how i feel
we can find purpose
purpose worthy of the lives they lived
worthy the country we love so today
i ask all americans to remember
remember those we lost and those are
left behind
but as remember as we all remember
i also ask us to act to remain vigilant
to say stay socially distant to mask
up get vaccinated when it's your turn
we must end the politics and
misinformations divided families
communities in the country it's cost too
many lives already
it's not democrats republicans who are
dying from the virus
it's our fellow americans it's our
neighbors our friends
our mothers our fathers our sons our
daughters
husbands wives
we have to fight this together as one
people
as the united states of america
that's the only way we're going to beat
this virus i promise you
the only way to spare more pain and more
loss the only way
these millstones no longer mark our
national mourning these milestones i
should say
no longer mark our national morning
let this not be a story of how far we
fell
but how far we climb back up
we can do this for in this year
profound loss we've seen profound
courage
from all of you on the front lines
i know the stress the trauma the grief
you carry
but you give us hope you keep us going
we remind us that we do take care of our
own
that we leave nobody behind
and while we've been humbled we have
never given up
we are america we can and will do this
in just a few minutes jill and i
kamal and doug will hold a moment of
silence here in the white house
the people's house your house
we ask you to join us
to remember so we can heal
to find purpose in the work ahead
to show that there is light in the
darkness
this nation will smile again this nation
will know sunny days again
this nation will know joy again and as
we do
we'll remember each person we've lost
the lives they lived the loved ones they
left behind
we will get through this i promise you
but my heart aches for you those of you
who are going through it right now
may god bless you all particularly those
who've lost someone
god bless you
all right and i believe that the
ceremony with the
the uh imhof harris
jill biden will be televised i don't
know if it's on the same stream
let's see i will looks like it will
all right so we will stay with it here
this scheduled for
now 6 15 p.m eastern time 3 15 p.m
pacific
looks like just some final preparations
being made
beetle greg liked it says via super chat
this this is what a president sounds
like
a number of different comments coming in
as many of you know over 500 000
official covet deaths at this point in
the united states the real number is
much higher
could be 570 600 650 000. we don't
really know
uh it's significant
okay just heard a little something there
will ymca play during this right yeah
well i mean listen
trump would never even give such a
speech
so it's it's a totally different
framework let's put it that way
and this is outside the white house this
is the same area where
after having coveted donald trump i
believe it is arrived
walked up to this balcony and defiantly
removed his mask
there's a very very different look this
for people wondering what's going on
this is going to be a
moment of silence involving joe and
jill biden as well as kamala harris and
doug
emhoff
thank you for being a real president mr
biden says
kirara
uh people on twitch trying to send super
chats you can't super chat
over there is a youtube only function
twitch sub message messages show up up
there nikki says you rock david love
from seattle
oh nikki for 15 months subscribe
beautiful thank you
having biden for president feels like a
relief
weight off says bryce
thanks bryce many people feeling that
way
certainly
it looks like it's just chatter
happening in the background
yeah i don't think that that's poorly
mic'd stuff we're supposed to be hearing
it sounds just like background chatter
okay also thanks to regina as well as
sure fire and scipio invicta for the
twitch subs a bunch of people signed up
with twitch
during the presentation
appreciate your hard work dave been
watching since the early 2010s on free
speech tv keep it up proud of you thank
you so much
daniel krieger says psa we have a fake
vouch
in the chat okay uh if moderators can
take care of that i assume that that's a
youtube
problem uh please go ahead and take care
of that if you can
the ceremony will continue
[Music]
very low audio level
[Music]
hey
[Music]
all right and that concludes uh joe
biden making a statement about a
horrible milestone
500 000 coronavirus deaths
um followed by a moment of silence
uh let's listen to what's going on here
100 000 that we have lost to this virus
let me go back to
john meacham very quickly john if you
want to finish your thought about the
power of empathy
presidents are leaders of people and we
want to know that the
humanity the grace that we would want in
a neighbor
in a friend is also the humanity and
grace that is in
the person who's in whose hands all of
our fates now rest
and i think the president showed that
anew this evening
john meacham thank you i'll be back with
a full wrap-up on
nbc nightly news for now i'm lester holt
in new york
all right so there it is everybody um i
have been
asked whether tomorrow i will be
covering joe biden's
state of the union address now first of
all in the first year of a presidency
it's not
typically called the state of the union
it's just an address before a joint
session
of congress but that being said february
23rd was the date originally floated
i'm not aware of any joe biden addressed
to congress tomorrow
people in the chat maybe can either
confirm or whatever
uh but i don't i don't think it's
tomorrow i believe that it's been
changed
to march if for some reason i got the
message wrong and that event is tomorrow
i will be covering it live tomorrow
night i don't believe that it is
and once we know uh the actual date
then i will announce it and we are going
to be covering it
uh for sure so that is going to do it
for me today if you're watching
on twitch we are going to raid
uh let's raid kit boga who i've learned
is a viewer of the david pakman show so
if you are watching on twitch we are
going to raid kit boga
if you are watching on youtube or
facebook this is going to
be the end of our programming today sign
up for the raid on twitch
and we'll be back with so much more
tomorrow and more clips coming up later
today
you